-How are you?
-I'm great.
-Welcome back.
You went down to McAllen, Texas.
-Yep.
And I was very glad --
You weren't the only one
who went,
but I have a lot of respect
for people who went down there
to actually see what
it was like on the ground.
What was your biggest takeaway
from what we had been told
about a place
like McAllen, Texas,
and what it was like
actually being there?
-You know,
the two biggest ones --
the first is this idea
that this is chaos
and they're being overrun
is preposterous.
I mean, people were just like,
"What are you even
talking about?" down there.
It's like, "This is life, yeah.
We live in McAllen.
Reynosa, Mexico,
is across the border.
And, you know, people come in,
they go back
for years and decades
and, actually, centuries
in American life, right?
This has been
a part of the country
where people move back and forth
across that river.
The idea that there is
some crazy invasion happening
was just entirely preposterous
and absent
from everyone I talked to there,
so that was the first thing.
The second thing
was just the level
of both courage and desperation
by the people
showing up at that border.
I mean, the stories you hear --
"The cartels come, and they
tried to recruit my oldest son,
and he said no,
and they shot and killed him.
So, now I have my youngest son,
and I took him on a 2,000-mile
journey to come up here
to come to your door, America,
and be like,
'Please, take me in because
I don't want to give the cartels
my only other living son.'"
Those are the kinds of stories
you're hearing
when you're watching the
President and other people
and his allies
talk about these people
like they're vermin
who's infesting the country.
You're talking about, literally,
some of the most courageous
people in the hemisphere.
-It is --
[ Applause ]
I mean, that's why I'm so happy
that people went down.
Melania Trump
also went down there.
To her credit. To go down.
With that said, Donald Trump,
he went to Duluth, Minnesota.
-Oh, you're just gonna
move right past the jacket.
-I mean, I don't even know
what to make of the jacket.
The jacket -- The amount of
"did she know, did she not?"
I mean, I feel like
it's something, you know --
-She's going to get a
face tattoo that says
"I hate all of you."
And everyone's gonna be like,
"Oh, what does it mean?
I don't know."
-She's like a Magic 8-Ball
that doesn't have a die in it.
-[ Laughs ]
-So you just shake it,
and it's just black water.
So, that -- I mean, I'm like,
I guess we could keep trying,
but I don't think we're
ever gonna get an answer.
-She went down there. Yeah.
-She went down there.
Donald Trump went to
Duluth, Minnesota,
to rage about
the immigration party --
the immigration problem,
I should say.
-It was the most perfect moment
that encapsulated
what this is really about.
We're down in McAllen. We're
talking to folks in McAllen.
We're talking to --
A guy I talked to,
had a conversation with --
20 years in CBP,
you know, border protection.
I talked to lawyers for migrants
and people that offer them,
you know, care.
And they're talking about,
"What a situation."
Meanwhile,
he flies north to Duluth
and, in a huge stadium of folks
all keyed up in Duluth,
is talking about
the scourge at the border.
And we're down at the
border like, "What are
you talking about?"
But that's the whole point.
He did this on the campaign.
You know, he would go to Kenosha
or he'd go to somewhere in Ohio
and talk about the border,
and people would be chanting,
like, going nuts about it.
Because it's not
actually the border.
Right?
It's this idea of invasion.
It's this idea
of the country's changing
in ways they don't like.
The border is a convenient
metaphor for that anxiety.
-Obviously, immigration
has been framed as a problem
for a really long time.
Is it safe to say
that the real issue
is that there are certain people
that don't see it
as an immigration problem
but as a diversity problem?
-More than that.
An existential problem
about what the country is.
I mean, Stephen Miller
is very clear about this.
Steven King,
the Iowa Congressman
who tweeted literal
Nazi propaganda a week ago.
These are people
that really think
that the nature of the country
existentially --
America won't be America
if it changes too much
demographically.
And they see themselves
as guarding against
that eventuality,
and they're very clear
about that.
And that's why it's very hard
to come to compromise
with these people
about legislation.
So, even when you go
and you say,
"We're gonna put money
into border security,"
which we've done every year.
Border-security numbers
are through the roof.
"We're going to have more people
patrolling the border."
Which we've done every year.
There's more people
patrolling the border.
They say, "Okay.
Now let's strike a deal."
And they say,
"No, we don't want a deal.
Because what we want to do
is change the demographic tide
of this country
to preserve the white majority
we have now."